هل يستطيع ماكرون
قيادة أوروبا وكيف فشلت
الخطط الفرنسية لذلك؟
الصين تهدد أمريكا وتستمر
بزيادة أسلحتها النووية،
رئيس وزراء بريطانيا يزور أوكرانيا
ويحدد مساعدات لندن لكييف،
وزيلينسكي يشيد بدوره
خلال الحرب الأوكرانية الروسية،..
إيران تحذر الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
وكوريا الشمالية تهاجم بايدن،
ألمانيا تعجز عن دعم أوكرانيا،
وبايدن يطالب بزيادة ميزانية الدفاع الأمريكية،.
حلف الناتو يعود بوعود جديدة لأوكرانيا..
البرلمان الباكستاني يحجب الثقة
عن عمران خان، وعمليات إطلاق نار
وطعن في إسرائيل،
لبنان يعلن إفلاسه والوضع يزداد
سوءا في بيروت
(خطة ماكرون)
تقارير توضح رؤية ماكرون لأوروبا
خلال رئاسته للاتحاد الأوروبي
قائمة على أن تكون أوروبا قوة
اقتصادية ودفاعية،
ماكرون سعى لاستغلال رئاسته
للاتحاد الأوروبي هذا العام لطرح رؤية
تبرزه كزعيم للقارة،
وفي رؤية ماكرون، تتمتع روسيا
بمكانة خاصة باعتبارها "جزءا من أوروبا"
، كما تحتل فرنسا مكانة اللاعب النشط
في قيادة "مشروع الحضارة الأوروبية".
لكن هذه الرؤية  انهارت واحترقت
خلال الحرب الروسية الأوكرانية،
(الصين أمام أمريكا)
الرؤوس النووية محور صراع
جديد بين بكين وواشنطن،
حيث تضغط الصين على أمريكا
لتخفض ترسانتها النووية من أجل الوصول
إلى التكافؤ وتحقيق مفهوم الردع.
أعلنت الصين  أنّها ستواصل "تحديث"
ترسانتها النووية، تحسبا لمواجهة واشنطن،
مطالبة كلاً من الولايات المتحدة وروسيا
بخفض مخزونهما من الرؤوس النووية،
غداة تعهّد الدول الخمس الكبرى
منع انتشار الأسلحة الذرية.
لكن تطبيق هذا التعهد على أرض الواقع
لن يكون سهلا في ظل تصاعد التوتر بين هذه القوى
إلى حد غير مسبوق منذ الحرب الباردة.
بينما أكدت الولايات المتحدة أن الصين
توسع ترسانتها النووية بما يقرب من
700 رأس حربي بحلول العام 2027
ولربما 1000 بحلول 2030.
وفي ما يتعلّق بمزاعم الولايات المتحدة
بأن الصين تزيد بشكل كبير إمكاناتها النووية،
تقول بكين أن هذا الأمر غير صحيح".
(لندن في صف كييف)
زيلينسكي يشيد بدعم بريطانيا ويدعو الدول الغربية
بأن تحذو حذوها
جاء ذلك بعد قيام بوريس جونسون
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني بجولة بصحبة
زيلينسكي في أحد شوارع العاصمة الأوكرانية
كييف
وقال جونسون
"نحن نضع حزمة جديدة من المساعدات المالية
والعسكرية، وهي شهادة على التزامنا
بنضال بلاده ضد الحملة البربرية لروسيا".
وأضاف أن بريطانيا ستعطي كييف 120
عربة مدرعة وأنظمة صواريخ جديدة مضادة للسفن.
(تهديد إيراني)
الرئيس الإيراني إبراهيم رئيسي يؤكد جدية
بلاده في "الحفاظ على الردع"
في مياه الخليج وبحر عمان،
وذلك في أعقاب اتهامات غربية لإيران
بالوقوف خلف هجوم على ناقلة نفط
يشغلها رجل أعمال إسرائيلي في بحر العرب،
وهو ما تنفيه طهران وحذرت من أنها سترد
على أي "مغامرة" عسكرية قد تستهدفها.
وأشار إلى ضرورة أن تحترم الولايات المتحدة
والدول الأوروبية تعهداتها بموجب الاتفاق
بشأن برنامج إيران النووي المبرم في فيينا
عام 2015.
(سخرية من بايدن)
هاجمت كوريا الشمالية، الرئيس الأمريكي
جو بايدن، ووصفته بـ"الرجل العجوز
الذي يعاني خرف الشيخوخة"،
عقب اتهام بايدن للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين بارتكاب جرائم حرب في أوكرانيا.
وتقول بيونغ يانغ إن "الحكاية الأخيرة
هي عن الرئيس التنفيذي الأمريكي الذي تحدث
بالسوء عن الرئيس الروسي
استنادا إلى معلومات لا أساس لها"،
في إشارة إلى اتهام بايدن للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بارتكاب جرائم حرب في أوكرانيا.
(خوف أم عجز)
برلين تعلن استنفاد إمكاناتها لإمداد كييف
بمعدات جيشها
صرحت وزيرة الدفاع الألمانية كريستين لامبرخت،
أن ألمانيا استنفدت كل إمكاناتها تقريبا
لإمداد أوكرانيا بمعدات من احتياطات جيشها
لكنها تعمل على عمليات تسليم تتم مباشرة
من قبل منتجي الأسلحة.
فهل تحاول ألمانيا بذلك تجنب المواجهة
مع روسيا أم أنها عاجزة حقا؟
(الأحداث والتطورات)
بعد قطيعة لخمسة أشهر
سفراء السعودية والإمارات
يعودون إلى بيروت لكن متى؟
جاء ذلك بعد أن أعلن لبنان إفلاسه!!
هيئة الأركان الأوكرانية: الجيش الروسي
خسر أكثر من 19 ألف جندي و722 دبابة
و1911 آلية مدرعة منذ بدء الحرب.
نوفوستي عن انفصاليي دونيتسك:
القوات الأوكرانية استولت على سفينتين
أجنبيتين في ميناء ماريوبول.
الجزائر ستزود إيطاليا ب٤ مليارات متر مكعب
من الغاز الطبيعي سنويا
الهند تشويش وصافرات استهجان من متطرفين
هندوس لحظة سماع الأذان
روسيا انسحبت من ثلاث محافظات
أوكرانية كييف وتشيرنيهيف وسومي
صور لمقبرة جماعية وانتشال ٤٠ جثة منها
قرب كييف
عمليات إطلاق نار وطعن داخل إسرائيل
خلفت ١٣ قتيلا خلال أسبوعين
السلطات الأوكرانية تطالب المواطنين
بمغادرة إقليم لوغانسك تحسبا لهجوم روسي واسع
بايدن يطالب بزيادة ميزانية الدفاع
لمواجهة روسيا والصين ولتعزيز الأمن الأوروبي.
فهل قلبت حرب روسيا وأوكرانيا
الموازنة الأمريكية رأسا على عقب
السفير الروسي لدى واشنطن،
العملية العسكرية جاءت نتيجة عدم استعداد
كييف لوقف الإبادة ضد الروس،
وعدم الالتزام بالاتفاقات الدولية.
السلطات الأوكرانية: مقتل 10 مدنيين
وإصابة 11 في هجمات روسية شرق أوكرانيا.
الإدارة العسكرية في دنيبرو:
قصف روسي ثان يدمر مطار دنيبرو
والبنية التحتية المجاورة بالكامل.
وزارة الدفاع الأوكرانية: دفاعاتنا الجوية
أسقطت طائرة روسية من طراز
"سوخوي-34" في ميكولايف جنوبي البلاد.
بابا الفاتيكان يدعو إلى هدنة في أوكرانيا
بمناسبة عيد الفصح تؤدي إلى مفاوضات وسلام،
وليس إلى استئناف للقتال.
الإدارة العسكرية في خاركيف:
الجيش الأوكراني دمر قافلة كبيرة
من المعدات الروسية كانت متجهة نحو إيزيوم.
• الدفاع الروسية:
• قواتنا استهدفت 86 منشأة عسكرية أوكرانية
منها مركزان للقيادة .
• تدمير منظومة دفاع جوي من طراز
"إس-300" (S-300) في مطار تشوغويف
العسكري الأوكراني.
اتفق وزراء خارجية حلف شمال الأطلسي
"ناتو" على تقديم حزمة جديدة وكبيرة
من الأسلحة لأوكرانيا استجابة لطلب كييف
وردا على ما جرى في بوتشا.
من جهتها تعهّدت مجموعة السبع الصناعية
الكبرى بمواصلة الضغوط على روسيا
ومحاسبة المسؤولين عما سمته الفظائع في بوتشا
أمّا كوليبا، وزير خارجية أوكرانيا فقال:
إما أن تساعدونا الآن، وأنا أتحدث عن مسألة أيام،
وليس أسابيع، أو ستأتي مساعدتكم
بعد فوات الأوان. وسيموت كثير من الأشخاص،
وسيفقد كثير من المدنيين منازلهم،
وسيتم تدمير كثير من القرى،
لأن هذه المساعدة ستكون قد وصلت متأخرة»
صور لقافلة عسكرية روسية ممتدة ل٨ أميال
كتيبة آزوف الأوكرانية تنشر صورا لجثث
جنود روس قتلوا في ماريوبول
البرلمان الباكستاني يصوت على حجب الثقة
عن حكومة عمران خان.
لم يكمل أي رئيس حكومة في باكستان ولايته،
إلا أن خان هو أول رئيس للوزراء
يقال من منصبه بحجب الثقة
زيلينسكي: سلمنا الترسانة النووية
دون ضمانات تحمي الشعب الأوكراني
وأضاف الرئيس الأوكراني أن الحرب لم تنتهي بعد
وأن الكثير من مناطق أوكرانيا محتلة
من قبل روسيا.. مضيفا أنهم طلبوا ضمانات أمنية
من الصين لحماية أوكرانيا
بايدن يوقع على قانون تعليق العلاقات التجارية
العادية مع روسيا وبيلاروسيا
زيلينسكي روسيا فشلت في دخول كييف
بسبب إرادة الأوكرانيين
الانفصاليون يعلنون أنهم باتوا يسيطرون
على 70% من ميناء ماريوبول
المفوضية الأوروبية تعلن جمع ٩ مليارات
دولار لدعم اللاجئين الأوكرانيين
الجيش الأوكراني يعلن استعداده لمواجهة كبيرة
شرق البلاد
القوات الروسية تكثف عملياتها للسيطرة
الكاملة على لوغانسك ودونيتسك
الجيش الأوكراني ينشر صورا لقاعدة روسية
مدمرة في مدينة خاركيف
مروحيات كا 52 الروسية تدمر رتلا عسكريا
أوكرانيا بالكامل
الحرب هدأت في مناطق واشتعلت
في مناطق أخرى من أوكرانيا،
والعالم يدخل صراعات دولية والرابح
من يخرج من هذه الأزمة بأقل الأضرار،
فكيف ستكون النهاية يا ترى؟